qutiop qui saisit la commission
européenne qutiop c'est cette régie
publique créée en 2009 qui a pour
objectif de déployer le réseau FTTH plus
connu sous le nom de réseau fibre
optique IFB vous présidez donc cette
régie aujourd'hui 16 avril vous demandez
à la Commission européenne de se
prononcer sur un éventuel manquement de
l'État français il faut saisir
aujourd'hui l'Europe pour faire avancer
le dossier à saint-quanttins en Yveline
il faut saisir l'Europe à partir du
moment où on n'est pas en endu et que on
sait que dans ce dossier nous sommes
aujourd'hui nous dans une situation où
la régie fibre optique a été pénalisée
par des manquements de l'État donc la
seule aujourd'hui structure une fois que
vous avez utilisé toutes les procédures
naturellement depuis pratiquement un an
c'est d'alerter par les outils
juridiques qui restent à notre
disposition l'état aujourd'hui le réseau
fibre optique pour les particuliers
n'est plus déployé par la Régie qutiope
la régie publique sur Saint-Quentin en
vous ne pouvez plus aujourd'hui
continuer à déployer ce réseau parce que
d'autres opérateurs sont en train de
faire leur propre réseau c'est bien ça
alors si vous voulez on est aujourd'hui
considéré à qutiop au niveau de l'État
comme étant un opérateur à partentière
sauf qu'au moment où l'État a demandé à
l'ensemble des opérateurs qutiop compris
de se prononcer sur les zones qu'elle
voulait fibrer l'ensemble des opérateurs
l'ont fait qutiop l'a fait et au moment
de la publication on a vu disparaître
cantiope du dossier ce qui fait que deux
opérateurs se sont prononcés pour yer la
fibre optique sur
saquentin c'est les opérateurs Orange et
SFR mais là avec une contradiction de
taille puisque comme quantiop a été
écarté le délai aujourd'hui que
proposent ces deux opérateurs sont
pratiquement étalés sur 8 à 10 ans ENF
ça fait déjà un an qu'on qu'on connaiss
ses intentions et aujourd'hui qutiob se
retrouve dans une situation lorsqu'il
appelle les autres opérateurs pour
coinvestir avec eux ceci nous font
comprendre que nous n'existons pas parce
que ce que vous souhaitez aujourd'hui
c'est pouvoir continuer à déployer ce
réseau cette fibre optique pour les
particuliers en travaillant main dans la
main on va dire avec les opérateurs
privés en vous partageant le le réseau
pour accéder sur les zones où c'est plus
compliqué leur laisser des zones où
c'est peut-être plus plus simple où il y
a plus de densité tout est possible
l'arcepp l'organisme de régulation a
défini des règles du jeu sur lequel
qutiope s'est naturellement positionné à
respecter ses règles et aujourd'hui ce
que l'on veut avec les opérateurs c'est
d'être un partenaire je veux dire avant
tout pour pouvoir déployer je dirais
l'aspect physique nous sommes pas un
opérateur de service donc c'est
aujourd'hui uniquement pour permettre à
ce que la fibre aille partout sur
SaintQuentin et le comble du comble
aujourd'hui c'est que nous sommes dans
une situation où on a par le biais de la
communé d'agglomération le soutien
économique pour avancer dans cette
démarche dans un temps de 2 ans et non
pas de 8 ans et aujourd'hui les
mécanismes qui ont été mis en place ce
que l'État aujourd'hui a mis en place
par le Commissariat Général
d'investissement nous empêche d'être un
acteur au même titre que les autres ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui la dynamique qui
pourrait être celle de Saint-Quentin ne
peut pas avoir lieu parce que on nous
écarte on va continuer à évoquer ce
dossier pour essayer d'y voir plus clair
avec cette simple question à quand la
fibre optique parce que c'est finalement
ce qui importe le plus sans doute aux
cquentinois on parle bien là de cquentin
en iveline pas de l'ensemble du
département des ivelines il y a cette
régie qutiope qui existe portée par
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin c'est
pour ça que tout à l'heure je l'évoquais
d'ailleurs dans les titres de cette
édition auparavant un petit micro
trottoir une petite pause attendez-vous
cette fibre optique et puis pourquoi
c'est la question que nous vous avons
posé
aujourd'hui là la fibre optique c'est
quoi la fibre optique moi je m'ener sur
mon téléphone et puis à la maison juste
pour regarder certaines choses donc
c'est pas trop trop important pour moi
oui à fond ouais j'attends la friv moi
je pense que ça va permettre au niveau
des opérations genre de choses de faire
des évolutions et des avantages pour la
société humaine non pas vraiment je
crois que c'est plutôt pour les
entreprises comme j'habite dans un
endroit où il y a déjà pas le dégroupage
la fibre optique oui je l'attends mais
il me semble pas qu'elle va arriver tout
de suite et et pourquoi tu l'attends
justement bah parce que pour les
téléchargements regarder des streamings
c'est quand même beaucoup plus agréable
j'ai le câble pour l'instant mais oui je
serai intéressé par la fibre optique et
pourquoi bah pour avoir des débits plus
importants sur Internet tant qu'à faire
autant avoir le meilleur avoir un débit
plus important il est là l'enjeu surtout
pour les poches qui sont les plus mal
desservies on a entendu un 5antinois
tout à l'heure il même connait même pas
le dégroupage sur le secteur où il
habite donc la fibre pour lui ce sera
une révolution oui je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la problématique sur 5ant
elle est totalement différente d'un
secteur ou d'un autre si vous allez à
manier l'amour dans les hameau de manie
vous dans une situation ubes que
aujourd'hui ils sont encore l'âge de
pierre là-bas et et la commité
d'agglomération dans son objectif c'est
de couvrir tout le monde même les hameau
c'est les hameau de manie ou le hameau
du lonet il en cours sont dans dans le
casre du déploiement le problème c'est
qu'on peut déployer aujourd'hui un
réseau mais si vous avez pas
d'opérateurs qui viennent sur ce réseau
en tout cas des grands opérateurs même
s'il y a des opérateurs alternatifs je
veux dire le choix est quand même
difficile par que les grands opérateurs
développent he juste pour pour être
clair sur ce dossier les grands
opérateurs sont prêts à déployer mais
sur les zone où il y a le plus de
densité c'est là leur priorité alors que
pour la ré publique c'est plus sur je
laiss la responsabilité aux opérateurs
d'annoncer là où ils vaulent déployer
euh vous leur poserez la question euh
moi je ne vous crois que ce que je vois
euh à la date d'aujourd'hui les Hau sont
pas du tout dans dans ce qu'on
appellerait dans le tuyau
euh si on regarde aujourd'hui les
calendriers de déploiement pour ce qu'
manie c'est en 2020 plus tard donc euh
voilà c'est pas tout de suite équé il va
y avoir un test des dès ce soir unement
al vous savez que dans le cadre des de
cantiup on a fait un test 5000 prises
dont un des Hau hein le village de de
manie euh enfin euh je sais plus le nom
exactement du quartier mais c'est dans
ce secteur là enfin là donc une
trentaine de pavillons aujourd'hui ils
sont éligibles et donc ils vont avoir ce
soir une réunion pour la possibilité
pour eux de choisir un opérateur certes
pant les grands ce qu'on appelle des
petits opérateurs alternatifs qui
amènent des services identiques que les
grands opérateurs on voit on a vu
quelques imagees du ce petit tableau de
récapitulatif du calendrier de
déploiement mais pour les opérateurs
privés la régie cantiop qui ne peut pas
poursuivre son travail et qui saisit
donc la Commission européenne que va
pouvoir faire la Commission européenne
imposer aux opérateurs de travailler
avec vous alors je crois que ce qu'on
peut attendre de la Commission
européenne c'est avant tout qu'elle dise
oui ou non une le service public peut je
dirais déployer dans une zone je dirais
entre guillemets réservée parce que les
certains opérateurs veulent faire pour
le privé mais elle peut aussi une régie
publique déployer et apporter sa pierre
jeis dans la démarche ça c'est la
première remarque une fois que cette
remarque je l'espère j'en suis sûr sera
positive les opérateurs seront je
l'espère amener à une table ronde pour
qu'on discute pour permettre d'aller
plus vite dans le déploiement nous on ce
qu'on cherche à Saint-Quentin c'est que
la population puisse avoir un service le
plus rapidement possible mais pas de
façon hégémonique et en plus on
développe avec la Régie uniquement ce
que j'appellerai le tuyau on fait pas
les services donc les services il
viennent automatiquement par les
opérateurs pour c'est juste deib juste
on va dire mais en tout cas de de fibrer
et pas
deateau de proposer des des bouquets
d'abonnement exactement vous regrettez
aujourd'hui ce choix d'avoir lancé
cantiop avec la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin parce
que ça a coûté de de l'argent alors non
on pe pas dire ça coûté de l'argent dans
le sens où aujourd'hui les les les
périodes test qu'on a et ce qu'on a en
retour parce que je vous rappelle qu'on
continue pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui équilibre le le budget de
qutiop et si on regarde aujourd'hui la
préemption du câble qui qui a eu a 7 ans
avec les recettes qu'on avec Numéricable
aujourd'hui on a non seulement remboursé
l'investissement mais on a même
modernisé ce réseau aucun regret si on
avait fait une autre démarche comme
beaucoup de collectivités l'ont fait à
travers des délégations de service
public on serait dans une situation
assez complexe d'ailleurs si vous
regarder un peu en France toutes les DSP
ces délégations de service public qui
sont aujourd'hui qui battent de l'elle
parce que les décisions qui ont été
prises à un moment donné et après la
mise en œuvre ne correspondait plus du
tout puisque la réglementation s'est mis
en place on a aujourd'hui des DSP qui
sont dans une situation catastrophique
avec des conflits très lourds on a fait
ce choix justement une régie parce que
on voulait adapter au fur et à mesure de
l'évolution des situations et on a bien
fait ce qui nous qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de mettre en attente tant
qu'on a pas résolu les problèmes on va
prendre de cas de figure si la situation
reste en l'état que la Commission
européenne n'intervient pas qu'est-ce
qui va se passer la fibre optique ce
sera pour quand et pour qui sur 550 ans
en nieline ce qui est sûr c'est que
qutiop ne déploierera pas un réseau euh
sans que les grands opérateurs soient
dessus ça n'a aucun sens on va pas
dépenser 30 millions d'euros entre 25 et
30 millions d'euros pour que je dire
aucun opérateur arrive ça ne peut se
faire qu'en coopération ça c'est ce
c'est le bon sens aussi du de la gestion
des des donniers publics après il y a
encore je dirais de l'espoir je veux
dire dans le courant de l'année 2013 et
la décision le le conseil
d'administration la régie que je prés je
préside prendra une décision à ce
moment-là en sachant que on a aussi je
vous le rappelle un réseau câblé qui est
géré par Numéricable qui lui-même
aujourd'hui s'il s'orientait vers le
FTTH pourrait rentrer dans cette ce
réseau fibre optique l'autre cas de
figure c'est justement la Commission
européenne intervient même très
rapidement ça peut accélérer les délais
pour l'accès à la fibreti aujourd'hui la
Commission européenne impose à l'état
concrètement que qu'antiop soit remis
dans dans dans le CER des opérateurs
nous sommes je dirais légitimes
pour que que les opérateurs nous
répondent et qu'il nous répondent à
travers les cofinancements qu'on a déjà
lancé déjà depuis mars il y a depuis un
an la B est donc dans le camp de
l'Europe pour savoir si oui ou non
demain ou alors il faudra attendre
après-demain pour avoir la fibre optique
c'est dans Camp de l'E europeope mais
c'est toujours aussi dans le camp de
l'État qui peut à tout
moment organiser une table ronde pour
que ensemble avec les opérateurs on
puisse faire le point et avancer
l'objectif c'est d'avancer c'est pas
juste parenthèse d'ailleurs parce que
vous évoquez l'État mais l'état jusqu'à
preuve du contraire est tenu par les
socialistes l'agglomération est tenue
par les socialistes et pour autant au
sein du même parti ça n'influence pas il
n'y a pas de discussion possible ça peut
être surprenant on aurait pu penser que
ça pourrait simplifier les choses moi je
vais vous dire he en tant que président
de de cantiop dans mon conseil
d'administration j'ai toutes les
communes donc toutes les tendances
politiques à l'unanimité imagine qu'il y
a des entrées différentes aussi
peut-être à l'unanimité je dirais des
membres on a du temps de la droite c'est
un dossier quand même qui a 4 ans ou du
temps de la gauche à avancé je dirais de
la même manière avec les haut débat
aujourd'hui la décision de de ne pas
reconnaître quantiop elle dat dit il y a
3 ans c'était sous l'ancien gouvernement
aujourd'hui les choses avancent pas
comme on souhaiterait c'est aujourd'hui
avec le gouvernement actuel bien sûr on
peut être un peu déçu je dirais pour les
deux on souhaiterait que ça qu'on nous
entende on est je dire un peu atypique
en France et le fait d'être atypique bah
on a tout tendance à pas trop nous
regarder et à pas n trop nous écouter ça
c'est vrai merci merci mAb pour ces
précision la régie publique qutiope donc
à 50 ans en Éveline qui saisit cette
Commission européenne c'est un peu la
sonnette d'alarme que vous tirez auprès
de l'État français pour dénoncer un
manquement on verra si l'état y répond
avant même que la Commission européenne
ne rendere sa décision